In the gi joe comics snake guys is one of those
characters that's had kind of a mysterious past
it was famously known as the silent ninja
this is morning night larry hama really
blossomed the character within an issue called
the silent interlude which had no words
just pictures when i did the comic i
made it character-centric i came up with the
backstory of storm shadow take snake eyes into the
clan larry hama created the modern day version of
what we know gi joe to be we try to find a balance
between what is pre-existing gi joe lore but also
finding a way of updating it giving people more
that opened up a world of opportunity let's
do the origin story before he's lost his voice
let's go shooting in japan was
super important for driving a story
when he goes to japan there's some energy
that you pick up from actually being there
i'm super excited for people to see what we're
building this is literally a stepping stone
into the gi joe universe
Welcome back everyone
this is going to be my snake eyes movie trailer
video for the gi joe origin story as you
can tell this is meant to be a new origin
for a new version of a gi joe cinematic
universe and knowing is half the battle
everyone post all the memes so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i'm sure at some point in everyone's
history here no matter how old you are you've
encountered a version of gi joe whether you just
watched the films from the early 2000s the cartoon
series or if you watched the og classic cartoon
series or if you're even older and you actually
had some of the larger toys that predated the gi
joe real american hero line when most people think
of the classic gi joe stories you're actually
thinking about the 1980s gi joe real american hero
story that was actually created by larry hama for
marvel comics as part of the brand new rebooted
toy line that hasbro was introducing we're talking
the classic era of saturday morning cartoons here
that original larry hama gi joe marvel comic
book was actually the first one that was ever
advertised on television as part of that animated
series and if you don't remember they actually did
an animated movie based on that series a long time
ago was in 1987 it's kind of hard to track down
but i think it's on amazon at the moment but the
whole idea is that they're trying to reinvigorate
the gi joe ip so this is meant to be a new
origin for new versions of all these characters
and they just wanted to start with a single
character instead of trying to do a straight up
full-blown gi joe movie but as you can see there
are a bunch of classic gi joe characters in this
like you even have the baroness so you have some
cobra characters you have scarlet that's your gi
joe character right there the reason why scarlett
is in this is because she has history with snake
eyes that predates gi joe they've been a lot of
different versions of their backstories in the
comics but this is mostly going to be referencing
the classic larry hama version because as you can
see from the featurette they basically brought
him onto the movie to help them sort of move the
timeline into present day so all these origin
stories that they're doing with the snake eyes
origin story is based on the classic version just
updated with modern references so if it's been a
hot minute since you've seen that classic animated
series or if you never read the original comics or
anything like that the whole idea is that snake
eyes and storm shadow were actually squad mates
during the vietnam war in the 1970s because it was
meant to be an origin story for the 1980s version
of the character obviously he's not meant to be
mute during this they'll show you how he became
mute eventually i don't know if they'll do it in
this film or one of the sequels but the whole idea
is that when zartan was killing his master he shot
snake eyes in the throat to keep him from shouting
out to warn him so that he could save himself
so he's mute because he got shot in the throat
in the funny story about them actually creating
his iconic black suit that he wears it looks so
badass is they actually said it was based on this
really weird situation that they ran into with
manufacturing the toy line i believe the story was
they were trying to sell an extra action figure as
part of the new 1980s rebooted toy line but in
order for it to be profitable enough for them to
justify doing it they actually had to find a way
to make the action figure without spending money
on a bunch of die for the actual plastic parts of
the figure so they said what if we don't color the
action figure at all we'll just release a black
action figure uncolored essentially so that's
like a version of the real story of how he wound
up getting that black costume but the reason why
they wanted to do snake eyes is this new origin
story is because he's probably one of the most
badass characters of all time in the gi joe line
so even though they don't totally clarify where
he was before he joined the arashi kage here it
sounds like maybe they'll use the war in iraq or
the war in afghanistan or one of the more recent
conflicts around the globe then he meets tommy
storm shadow storm shadow's real name is tommy
arashikage and tommy offers him a place in the
arashikage so he brings him to japan here so when
telling the origin of snake eyes they're also
giving an origin story for storm shadow as well
so they can kind of explain their relationship and
present day and why they're such bitter rivals
but also do a version of an origin story for
some of the gi joe characters like scarlet and
some of the cobra characters like the baroness
the actual synopsis for the movie just reads
an ancient japanese clan called the arashikage
welcomes tenacious loner snake eyes after
he saves the life of the heir apparent
that's storm shadow that they're talking about
upon arrival in japan the arashikage teach him
the ways of the ninja warrior while also providing
him something he's been longing for a home
however when secrets from snake eyes past are
revealed his honor and allegiance get tested
even if that means losing the trust of those
closest to him but henry golding said this opening
fight scene from the trailer is just supposed to
be them showing you some classic snake eyes moves
like they wanted to do the classic uzi shot
from the original series but you have a couple
arashikage characters like storm shadow and
akiko is the other character here you see
her in the later trailer she's one of the fellow
ninjas training as part of the arashikage under
blind master she might be a version of the jinx
character that was played by elodie young during
the gi joe retaliation movie most of you probably
remember her more recently though as elektra from
marvel's daredevil on netflix and the defenders
she actually kind of feels like an electra type
character so even though this version of the
character is named akiko i think it's meant to
be the same concept peter mensah is playing their
blind master most of you probably know a version
of that original origin story this sort of sets
up the idea of their rivalry during the animated
series and some of the later stories they flash
back to explain what their big falling out was
but this movie is meant to give you like the full
version of that because in the classic comics like
they feature the classic comic with larry hama
where he told his origin story they gave you sort
of a short version of that this is just meant
to be the full version originally the story is
is the storm shadows character who's known as
soft master within the arashikage wanted their
sensei blind master to teach them the seventh
step to the sun technique which would allow you
to kill your opponent within seven blows in that
version of the story blind master is supposed to
be his uncle so they're actually family members
like storm shadow's real last name is rashikage
after the name of the clan they call him the heir
apparent during this movie so like he's supposed
to eventually take over the clan someday but their
sensei blind master refuses to teach him the move
and instead seems like he favors snake eyes so
they try to set it up as this big jealousy thing
with storm shadow being jealous of snake eyes and
killing their sensei blind master in revenge snake
eyes retaliates to try and get revenge for the
death of their master blames storm shadow thinking
that he killed their master this whole time so
that also extends into present day he holds this
grudge against him for the rest of their life
but then later it's found out that zartan is
part of cobra was actually manipulating things
from behind the scenes and he's the person that
really killed their master so it's just a way to
show you that even though they have this intense
rivalry that extends into present day when they're
part of gi joe and part of cobra they still have
this deep connection to each other so they're
gonna try and develop that during this movie
it's sort of like captain america in the winter
soldier after they meet again after bucky has
become winter soldier and killed a ton of people
like he's my friend even though he's done a lot of
really really bad stuff you see a couple different
fights with storm shadow on his own fighting the
other yakuza interestingly enough they did not
reveal who the main villain of the movie is going
to be if it's going to be somehow related to
the rise of cobra in the background if they're
trying to develop a new version of an origin story
for that organization of those characters i know
there'll be a lot of comparisons with shangshi in
the legend of the ten rings another big martial
arts based movie that's coming out just a little
while after this shanghai the legend of the ten
rings is coming out in september this is coming
out at the end of july right after the black widow
movie the big difference is that snake eyes is
drawing more on japanese history with ninjutsu
in shengshin the legend of the ten rings is
drawing more on chinese history and mythology
through kung fu the funny thing about shanghi
is that you'll recognize they use the exact same
music track in this trailer that they used in the
shanghai trailer they released a little while ago
the whole idea with shangshin the legend of the
ten rings is the character shengshi actually
comes from a comic book that was titled master
of kung fu but he was sort of marvel's version
of bruce lee so interesting coincidence that larry
hama who was actually an editor at marvel when he
started that classic gi joe comic book so it all
goes back to marvel in the end even though the
history of gi joe pre-dates marvel comics by a lot
like gi joe goes back to the 1940s there was the
original line of action figures the really big
ones maybe some of you if you're a little bit
older you had one of those like even my grandpa
who fought during the korean war in the 1950s grew
up with a version of gi joe so far the movie seems
pretty decent i think they made the right call in
trying to sort of reboot the gi joe universe and
start with the cooler characters and just focus
on individual characters instead of trying to do
everything all at once i think the idea is they
have direct snake eye sequels and then eventually
you'll start seeing some of the other gi joe
characters the other cobra characters then within
like three or four years maybe way down the road
you'll actually see a brand new full-blown gi joe
movie like they're gonna do at the marvel avengers
route you do the individual character movies then
you build up to the team up movie their version
of avengers would be a gi joe film so even more
marvel references like based on a story that was
done for marvel comics now doing the movies in the
marvel movie way and even way back when they were
getting ready to cast channy tatum as a version of
duke chris evans was supposedly up for a role as
that character before they went on channing tatum
and if you don't remember ray park darth maul
himself played that version of snake eyes in those
2000s movies but everyone post all your reactions
in the comments below let me know what else do you
want them to do with the gi joe ip just because
this is the brand new beginning of a new cinematic
universe the only big cameos that i'm expecting
during the movie would probably be like larry hama
himself in the background of one of the shots he's
sort of like the stan lee of the gi joe universe
we also have marvel loki episodes that are going
to start releasing in a couple weeks i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of that while you wait for everything click
here for that brand new loki trailer and easter
eggs and click here for my brand new eternals
teaser trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!